you have done a lot of deep thinking
about the world about yourself this kind
of introspection
how do you think
If You by way of advice but just
practically speaking
day to day how do you think about
difficult problems with the world
first of all I take time off
like mother the the most important thing
I do
I think as a writer as a scientist that
I meditate I spend about two hours every
day in silent meditation
observing as much as possible
non-verbally what is happening within
myself focusing you know Body Sensations
the breath
thoughts keep coming up but I try not to
give them attention don't try to drive
them away just let them be there in the
background like some background noise
don't engage with the thoughts
because the mind is is constantly
producing stories with words these
stories come between us and the world
they don't allow us to see ourselves or
the world like for me the most shocking
thing when I started meditating like 23
years ago
I was given this simple exercise to just
observe my breath coming in and out of
the nostrils
not controlling it just observing it
and I couldn't do it for more than 10
seconds I for 10 seconds would try to
notice oh now the breath is coming in
it's coming in it's coming you know it
stopped coming in and now it's going out
going out 10 seconds and some memory
would come some thought would come some
story about something that happened last
last week or 10 years ago or in the
future and it the story would hijack my
attention it would take me maybe five
minutes to remember oh I'm supposed to
be observing my my breath
if I can't observe my own breath because
of these stories created by the mind how
can I hope to understand much more
complex things like the political
situation in Israel the Israeli
Palestinian conflict the Russian
invasion of Ukraine if all these stories
keep coming I mean it's not the truth
it's just the story your own mind
created so first thing train the mind to
be silent and just observe so two hours
every day and I go every year for a long
retreat between one month and two months
60 days of just Sonic meditation silent
meditation for 60 days yeah to train the
mind forget about your own stories just
observe what is really happening
and then also on other throughout the
day
have an information diet
people are today many people are very
aware of what they feed their body what
enters their mouth mouth
be very aware of what you feed your mind
what enters your mind having information
diet
so for instance I read long books
and I prefer like you know I do many
interviews I prefer three hours
interviews two five minutes interviews
uh the long format is in it's not always
feasible
but you can go much much deeper
um so I would say an information diet be
very careful about what you feed your
mind give preference
to big chunks over small uh books over
Twitter yes books over Twitter
definitely
and then you know when I encounter a
problem a difficult intellectual problem
then
um I give it I I let the problem lead it
lead me
where it goes and not where I want it to
go
if I approach a problem with some
preconceived idea solution and then try
to impose it on the problem and you know
just find confirmation bias just find
the evidence that supports my view it's
this is this is easy for the mind to do
and you don't learn anything new
do you take notes do you start to
concretize your thoughts
on paper
I read a lot I don't I don't usually I
don't take notes then I start writing
and when I write I write like a torrent
just right now is the time you read you
didn't meditation now it's the time to
write write don't stop just right so I
would write from memory
and I'm I'm not afraid of formulating
say Big Ideas big theories and putting
them on paper
the danger is once it's on paper or not
on paper on the screen in the computer
you get attached to it and then you
start with confirmation bias to build
more and more layers around it and you
can't go back and then it's very
dangerous
but I I trust myself that I have to some
extent the ability to press the delete
button the most important button in the
keyboard is delete yeah
I I write and then I delete I write and
then I delete and because I trust myself
that I'll have the every time I come to
press delete button I feel bad like it's
a kind of pain and I created this it's a
beautiful idea and I have to delete it
but you're still brave enough to press
delete I try and hopefully I do it
enough times and this is important
because in the long term it enables me
to play with ideas I have the confidence
to start formulating
some Brave idea most of them turn out to
be nonsense
but I trust myself not to be accused not
to be attached not to become attached to
my own nonsense
so it gives me this room for playfulness
I will be emissive I didn't ask for
people interested in hearing you talk
about meditation if they want to start
meditating what advice would you give
and how to start you mentioned you
couldn't hold the fur you couldn't hold
your attention on your breath for longer
than 10 seconds yes first
so how did they start on this journey
first of all it's a difficult Journey
it's not fun it's not recreational it's
not kind of time to relax it can be very
very intense the most difficult thing at
least in the meditation I practice uh
vipassana which I learned from a teacher
called Essen goenka the most difficult
thing is not the silence it's not the
sitting for long hours it's what comes
up
everything you don't want to know about
yourself yeah this is what comes up so
it's very intense and difficult if you
go to a Meditation Retreat don't think
you're going to relax
so what is what's the experience for
meditation and tree when everything you
don't like comes up first for 30 days it
depends what comes up anger comes up
you're angry yeah for days on end you're
just boiling with anger everything makes
you angry
again something that happens right now
or you remember something from 20 years
ago and you start boiling with it's like
I I never even thought about this
incident but it's some it was somewhere
stalled with a huge huge
pile of anger attached to it and it's
now coming up and all the anger is
coming up maybe it's boredom
you know
30 days of meditation you start getting
bored and it's the most boring thing in
suddenly no anger no it's the most
boring I I another second I scream
I mean and boredom is one of the most
difficult thing to deal with in life I
think it's closely related to death
death is boring you know in many movies
death is exciting it's not exciting when
when he died ultimately it's it's
boredom nothing happens it's the end of
exciting things and many things in the
world happen because of boredom to some
extent people start entire Wars because
of Bordeaux people quit relationships
people quit jobs because of boredom and
if you never learn how to deal with
boredom you will never learn how to
enjoy peace and quiet
because the way to peace passes through
boredom
and and from what I experience with
meditation I think
but maybe it was the most difficult
maybe at least in the top three like
much more difficult to say than anger or
pain when pain comes up you feel heroic
I'm feeling pain
when boredom comes up
brings it you know with depression and
feelings of worthlessness and it's
nothing I'm nothing
the way the peace is through boredom uh
David Foster Wallace said the key to
life is to be unborable
uh yeah it's just a different
perspective on what you're talking to is
there truth to that yes I mean it's
closely related I would say like I look
at the world today like Politics the one
thing we need more than anything else is
boring politicians
we have a super abundance of very
exciting politicians who are doing and
saying very exciting things and we need
boring politicians and we need them
quickly and
yeah the weighty pieces through boredom
that applies in more ways than one